woher stammen kometen die super schnell
durch das sonnensystem rasen und in den
interstellaren raum aufbrechen um dann
niemals wieder zurückzukehren
das ist eine der großen ungeklärten
fragen der astronomie ein japanisches
forschungsteam hat jetzt den weg zweier
objekte analysiert die sich für immer
aus dem sonnensystem entfernt
dabei sind sie dem rätsel auf die
schliche gekommen klicks und science
fiction hier gibt es spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ja nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen für
astrophysikerin und astrophysiker
weltweit ist es mittlerweile relativ
easy die flugbahn von kometen zu
berechnen klar ist dass nicht alle
kometen geschlossenen bahnen um die
sonne folgen es gibt auch einige
ausbrecher die sich sehr rasant durch
unser sonnensystem bewegen auf dem weg
in den interstellaren raum und von dort
auch nie wieder zurückkehren sie rasen
auf hyper bullischen bahnen durchs
sonnensystem wobei die kometen die sonne
eben nicht um kreisen sondern nur genau
einmal an ihr vorbeiziehen der
interstellaren raum ist das stern ferne
weltraum gebiet innerhalb einer galaxie
der begriff kommt aus dem lateinischen
inter stellas was so viel bedeutet wie
zwischen den sternen von uns aus gesehen
kommt vorher noch die heliopause die oft
auch als grenze unseres sonnensystems
bezeichnet wird dahinter beginnt dann
laut definition der interstellaren raum
doch woher stammen diese objekte die
sich super schnell durch unser
sonnensystem bewegen einmal an der sonne
vorbei ziehen und dann auf
nimmerwiedersehen in den interstellaren
raum abtauchen möglicherweise entstehen
solche kometen an einen sehr weit
entfernten ort und bewegen sich dann von
einem anderen planeten system aus durch
den interstellaren raum dabei durchquert
das objekt dann mehr oder weniger
zufällig unser sonnensystem bevor es
dieses dann auch wieder verlässt in
einem anderen möglichen szenario dagegen
bewegt sich solch ein komet zunächst auf
einer stabilen umlaufbahn sehr weit
entfernt von der sonne ein großes objekt
zieht vorbei und es entstehen
gravitations wechselwirkung diese sorgen
dann dafür dass der komet aus seiner
umlaufbahn gezogen wird und quasi in
unser sonnensystem clubs so erst werden
wir dann in die lage versetzt ihn zu
beobachten und zu sehen wie ihr dann
weiter in den interstellaren raum rast
ein japanisches forschungsschiff
diese beiden möglichen szenarien genauer
ins visier und analysierte die flugbahn
von zwei cometen die bei diesen beiden
möglichkeiten zu erwarten sind ihre
ergebnisse verglichen die fachleute dann
mit den daten zwei interstellare objekte
1 und 2 ubisoft über beide hatten wir
hier bei kings und science fiction
ausführlich berichtet im oktober 2017
war humor entdeckt worden
eine echte premiere das erste innerhalb
des sonnensystems beobachtete objekt das
als interstellar klassifiziert wurde in
einem weiten bogen flog nur um die sonne
und dann wieder ab in richtung des
interstellaren raumes aufgespürt wurde
das objekt zum großen bedauern der
fachleute erst als es schon bei seiner
abreise war anders beim kometen 2
ubisoft dieses interesse der objekt
wurde im sommer vergangenen jahres von
einem amateur astronomen entdeckt und
zwar direkt bei seiner ankunft er bewegt
sich auf einer hyper bullischen bahn
durch das sonnensystem ende des jahres
wird er der erde auf 300 millionen
kilometer nahe kommen und das
sonnensystem dann wieder verlassen der
vergleich der theoretischen berechnungen
mit den beiden interstellaren objekten 1
humor und zwei borissov ließ das
japanische forschungsteam zu einem
klaren ergebnis kommen demnach ist das
interstellare ursprung szenario
wahrscheinlicher heißt also dass die
kometen nach ihrer passage durch das
sonnensystem nicht nur in den
interstellaren raum verschwinden sondern
wohl auch von außerhalb des
sonnensystems stammt in ihrer studie
zeigen die fachleute außerdem dass
objekte in der größe eines gasplaneten
in der lage sein müssten kometen mit
langen umlaufbahn zu destabilisiert
objekt den gasriesen größe die sich in
der nähe des sonnensystems zu finden
könnten also für die pfade solcher
kometen sorgen harvard-professor wir
sind nicht allein exklusiv-interview zu
humor und aliens anklicken anschauen und
klicks um science-fiction abonnieren da
haben wir ja den berühmten professor le
prom loeb der die these vertrat humor
könnte ein alien objekt seien exklusiv
interviews also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleiben dran